be killed in an attack on a tv tower and
a holocaust memorial here in the capital
meanwhile a 40-mile long convoy of
russian reinforcements is closing in on
this city today we saw evidence of the
devastation it could bring at least 10
people were killed when russian missiles
and rockets targeted the cultural center
of ukraine's second city of kharkiv
ukraine's president vladimir zelinsky
has accused russia of committing a war
crime our security and defense editor
deborah haynes has this now on the
russian assault
in one moment
everything changed
a russian cruise missile piercing the
heart of ukraine's second city
[Music]
carnage
chaos
and inevitable casualties
they hunt for survivors in the wreckage
of the local government building
[Music]
carefully carrying away the dead
there is a lot of damage there are
killed and wounded a lot of them this
place was renamed freedom square after
ukraine regained its independence from
the soviet union
now it symbolizes the threat this
country's freedom once again faces
no longer clean shaven ukraine's wartime
president addressed eu politicians
his desire to join the bloc and their
desire to welcome him unbowed by
russia's pressure not to we are fighting
for our rights
for our freedoms
for life for our life and now
we're boring for we're fighting for
survival
and this is the highest of our
motivation
but what a price ukraine is paying
a tv station in the capital struck while
miles of russian armor masses around the
outskirts while miles of russian armor
advanced towards the city
caught in the crossfire are families
like sophia's
she and her three children take shelter
in the basement of their apartment block
whenever there's danger how has it
affected your children this situation
well my middle child
mark he is
probably
the one who has reacted
who's been hurt the most
because he can't really understand
that's being the hardest on him
my daughter she's older she's just grown
uh older in a day in a minute and how
are you finding things at the moment
it's a bit hard well
it's a hard thing
the only hard thing
for me
right now is
to
make my breath my brother
understand that
the war still has a way to run as
civilians too vent their fury
this footage taken in the coastal city
of molitopol
defiance but also much more danger in
the days ahead
debra haynes sky news kiev
well cities right across this country
are preparing themselves for a russian
escalation skies alex rossi spent the
day in dinipro southeast of kiev where
people have been creating makeshift bomb
shelters and preparing weapons alex sent
this report on ukraine's defense
every night now the air raid sirens wail
and people scramble for safety
this war is getting uglier as men women
and children cower for another night in
the darkness
of god
this is a place that is awaiting its
fate the united nations is moving all
non-essential staff and their families
this group heading for the border
on the roads to the south ukrainian
armor rumbles to meet the growing threat
these troops advancing to reinforce the
defense of this region
inside the city there is an atmosphere
of paranoia and suspicion
as rumors of russian spies circulate
this man was detained at gunpoint
and all the time roads and buildings are
being fortified
this is a fight for the soul of this
country
i'm here because i think that everyone
should
unite in our efforts and
maybe i can't
kill someone but i can help in other way
these people want to fight but for now
will offer their support any way they
can the territorial defense has so many
volunteers they can't all join at once
there is a real sense of fear and
apprehension people are extremely scared
about what is happening to their country
but the levels
of resistance here are immense it seems
that anyone who is able to pick up a gun
or fill up a sandbag
is coming forwards in defiance of the
russian invasion
david
foreign
[Music]
but as this brutal war descends further
it will be the innocent who bear the
brunt of russia's aggression
there will be many more frightening
nights
underground
alex rossi sky news dineep pro
well let's just remind you of where
today's most devastating attacks took
place and a russian strike on a kiev tv
tower is said to have killed five people
while a number of ukrainian tv stations
were
taken off the air that attack close to
the center of kiev came shortly after
moscow warned that it was preparing to
strike targets inside this city
elsewhere a massive explosion hit a
regional administration building in
kharkiv's main square killing at least
10 people injuring 35 and in bravery a
airstrike left a military air base on
fire
there is growing concern that russia
could be about to deploy some of its
more destructive weaponry u.s officials
say that firma barrack missiles which
are capable of killing anyone inside a
building they target are at russia's
disposal let's bring in our security and
defense editor
uh debra haynes and deborah first of all
i mean it does seem as if the net is
closing here yes well that attack on the
tv station inside kiev was really one of
the first times you've actually seen a
web your weapons deployed right in the
center um and we've had uh there's been
a bit of gunfire uh just a few minutes
ago in the distance and this those
images really stark images of the column
of armor moving towards the city and
very much a sense that um the the the
terror that has been um
launched on other cities in terms of the
weapons used and the devastation caused
could now be coming here and it seems as
well that regardless of what threats the
western world makes to president putin
um and what uh you know
inside ukraine as well um saying that
this is it's
madness what is happening here it
doesn't seem to be deterring him at all
and he seems intent on continuing yeah
and as for
talks there was said to be
with a first round of talks took place
they said there would be a second round
they'd come back with proposal is that
now diplomacy now out of the window do
you think no it's not out the window but
um as things stand there's clearly no
obvious route away from this um the
ukrainians have made very clear they
will fight the last breath flight fight
to the last drop of blood and the images
that we saw um particularly at the end
of of the piece that i did of those
civilians in militipole in the south on
the coastline literally standing in the
road in front of this column of armored
vehicles coming towards them and you
didn't see it in the piece but there was
a russian soldier standing there as well
with a rifle shooting it into the air um
obviously looking nervous at how to
handle this situation it's not a
military against a military it's a
military against a civilian an unarmed
civilian who is literally willing to
risk their lives to try to stop them in
their track the complete reversal of the
listener gunshots
the complete reversal of what president
putin had been saying the narrative that
he was here to to get rid of this um
this
neo-nazi regime here utter nonsense and
even more insulting because the
president himself is jewish
the bravery here i mean you know has
been astonishing of the
the military and the the people
but
inevitably do you think that uh kiev
does fall to the russians
i certainly think that if the russian
military is intent on continuing with
its invasion with the power the
firepower that it has that
on balance even with the greatest will
which the ukrainian military clearly has
um it's it's just a it's got superior
firepower i mean they have weapons you
talked about the thermobaric weapons
they have weapons at their disposable at
their disposal which have the ability to
inflict
devastating casualties and cost which
would ultimately lead to a surrender i
mean the hope is that that there is some
way to prevent that but just to give you
a little example of of the toll on
civilians a doctor called texted me this
evening from the main children's
hospital which i visited yesterday to
say that two children had just been
brought in a sister and a brother and
they'd just witnessed their mother die
in an artillery attack um the little
girl had been wounded the doctor said
she would survive and he said that the
boy who was only about 10 had bear and
basically lost the ability to talk due
to the shock that had been inflicted
upon him by this debra thank you very
much indeed
well russia's uh actions have provoked
uh a pretty strong rebuke from nato's
allies and also from the prince of wales
today there was also a mass walkout at
the human rights council meeting when
russia russia's foreign minister
addressed members
while in search of a diplomatic solution
to the crisis prime minister boris
johnson traveled to poland and estonia
today but he was met with a barrage of
criticism and questions from one
ukrainian angry at the uk's response
sky's alistair bunkel has this on the
diplomatic anger being felt
the diplomatic wheels are still turning
even as vladimir putin's tanks are
rolling closer to kiev
boris johnson was on a tour of eastern
europe to reassure nato allies but for
all the talks he would have had with
fellow leaders today it was an emotional
plea from a ukrainian journalist at a
press conference in poland that cut
straight to the point
you're talking about more sanctions
prime minister but roman abramovich is
not sanctioned he's in london his
children are not in the bombardment his
children are there in london
putin's children are in netherlands
in germany
in mansions where all this mansion
seized i don't see that
i see that my family members that my
team members are saying that we are
crying we don't know where to rob i'm
acutely conscious that there is not
enough that we can do
to
as a uk government uh to help in the way
that you want
the united nations in geneva was the
center for more diplomacy but not the
meeting that many had hoped for
the u.s secretary of state anthony
blinken and the russian foreign minister
sergey lavrov were both due to be here
but neither came lincoln stayed in the
united states and sergey lavrov said
that because of the ban on russian
aircraft through european airspace he
was unable to travel
and so in their absence went any hope
that the two men might meet in private
and find some sort of breakthrough
instead the russian foreign minister
gave a televised address and as he did
western diplomats stood up and walked
out
and the u.s secretary of state also
speaking remotely suggested russia could
be kicked out of the united nations
human rights council
council members should stop using
language implying that all sides bear
equal responsibility for the unprovoked
attack of one side
this isn't even handed
it's wrong the british foreign secretary
was there in person and she had this to
say to vladimir putin the blood is on
putin's hands not just of innocent
ukrainians but the men he has sent to
die
he is violating international law
including the un charter and multiple
commitments to peace and security
on an official visit in the uk prince
charles spoke out in defense of
democracy and open society
we are seeing those same values under
attack today
in ukraine
in the most unconscionable way
in the stand we take here we are in
solidarity
with all those who are resisting brutal
aggression
the western unity has been strong and
the sanctions tough there is almost
certainly more to come but whilst it
might have shocked president putin it
hasn't stopped
alastair sky news geneva
well the united nation uh sorry the
united states is expelling some
intelligence operatives at the united
nations uh the expulsion of the russian
working for the un is in addition to the
12 russian u.n diplomats that washington
has already ordered to leave the country
over national security concerns our u.s
correspondent
mark stone is in washington first of all
mark tell us more about
these expulsions
yes the latest announced today which
brings to 13 the number of russian
diplomats on u.s soil who will have to
leave by the end of this
week yesterday the americans announced
that 12 diplomats working at the un uh
the russian mission to the united
nations which of course is in new york
on russian soil would have to leave and
they've added one
to that number today um it's one of a
flurry of bits of news that have come
out from various parts of of the from
this side of the atlantic over the
course of the past few hours from the
state department
we've had a background briefing at which
they've been giving a little more uh
detail on their view of president
putin's state of mind they are certainly
concerned
that he is a man isolated from his own
advisors that he may not be seeing
receiving
advice so he certainly won't be
receiving dissenting advice and that is
a particular concern although it's
interesting they will not pass judgment
specifically on his state of mind
whether or not he is rational or
irrational i i've been struck at how
careful the language from the americans
has been there in terms of the pentagon
and picking up what you were talking to
deborah haynes about um it's their view
here at the pentagon the defense
department that is that the thermobaric
weapon that we've been talking about
that russian click russia
possesses they do not believe it has
been used on the battlefield at the
moment although they do think that the
means to deliver it is on the
battlefield so a concern there and then
on this large column of russian vehicles
that are supposedly heading uh your way
to kiev um they are
clear that that this convoy has been
bogged down it has slowed down there are
massive supply problems with it it is
running out of fuel the soldiers within
it it is the view of the pentagon are
running out of both uh fuel and of food
of course we are part of an information
war how ac war how accurate is this
information we don't know but it is
certainly that that is the view the
pentagon uh is um is presenting so so an
awful lot of information
there from various different departments
and it is the view also of the uh
defense department here that 80 percent
of russia's forces that it amassed on
that border are now in ukraine only 20
remaining still a large fighting force
but 20 percent left the other side of
the border
right and mark uh president biden
preparing
for his big speech
yes mark
the state of the union which will be in
this building behind me um tonight is
something usually that is
grips many americans but beyond america
it is not something that is a massive uh
focus but i think undoubtedly tonight it
will and i think president biden over
the course of the past week has largely
ripped up what he wanted to say and a
large part of this speech will be about
ukraine will be about casting he the
american president
not maybe not as the world's policeman
but certainly as the leader of the free
world cementing that position as the man
who has managed uh to isolate to ghana
support globally really very easily to
isolate russia in a way that no country
has ever been isolated before he has a
global audience tonight when he makes
this address a big moment for president
biden and he will want to make an impact
mark thank you very much indeed well
with the kremlin increasingly isolated
by economic sanctions and russian
societies starting to feel the bite
vladimir putin faces a growing domestic
problem how much are his people and
those in his inner circle willing to pay
for the cost of this war we've heard
from one of president putin's advisors
who's growing increasingly concerned by
the behavior of his boss let's go live
to moscow and our international affairs
editor dominic waghorn and dominic what
did the advisor have to say to you
andre cortonov is uh somebody who we are
used to on our televisions um justifying
uh his boss or sorry his president's
actions um not so much an apologist but
certainly defending vladimir putin in
syria and in other arenas of action uh
today though he's uh very critical of
the president he said he's in shock uh
he's depressed and he's not the only one
i think there are those in the foreign
policy establishment who can't
understand what putin is up to and
frankly are stunned and in disbelief
that this invasion happened this is what
andre cortunov had to say to me earlier
for
a long time
i
thought that
a military operation
was not
feasible
it was not plausible you know i had my
own cost-benefit analysis
and even if you put aside all other
considerations
i thought that
to go into ukraine is not in russia's
interests
keep in mind
the collateral damage
which is likely to happen after such an
operation but apparently you know
my cost benefit analysis
did not coincide with that in the
kremlin
so i had to wake up to a new reality and
i have
now not just
you know me but all of us will have to
live in this new reality
that's your dry foreign policy analyst
analysis how do you feel about this
today what are your emotions today well
you know i
i'm
trying to keep
going i'm trying to
continue doing what i'm doing but of
course i'm depressed you know all of us
are depressed
and i think that
it's it's very embarrassing
for all of us not only because we turned
out to be wrong but uh also because of
course you know
russia
and all russians will be in a difficult
position
in
in many countries
not even only western countries but all
over the place for a long time
and
there are many questions to which we
don't have answers
and does that make you wonder about the
the state of your president's mind
well you know
he has his own
vision
maybe you know he
believes that
this damage is acceptable
i don't know
i don't know it's
it's hard to tell
and you're someone who's
supported vladimir putin in the past
where you've thought fit and you advised
the kremlin and today you're depressed
about the way things are going yeah of
course you know i'm depressed i think
many of us are depressed i think that
there are many people in the kremlin who
should be depressed
because
the price
will be substantial
mark and what he said afterwards was
that he thinks that those advisers
around putin who've been pushing for
better development for prosperity have
basically been beaten in the argument by
those who are much closer to putin now
uh the securocrats if you like the
generals the military commanders and the
intelligence officials who have said to
putin it's about survival now they have
persuaded putin that the west is out to
get him and wants uh regime change wants
to topple putin from power and therefore
said that this action is necessary while
those like cortuna were horrified at the
likely cost not just in terms of death
but russia's standing in the world is
prosperity so that battle seems to be
won in the kremlin by these hard-liners
around putin and i think that raises
some pretty alarming prospects about
what is likely to happen next if those
hardliners remain in the ascendancy
which uh seems most likely then they
will continue pushing putin to do his
worst in ukraine and one other point he
said i asked him particularly not just
about putin's state of mind and you
heard as far as he was prepared to go
there which is that putin just doesn't
have the same vision as could tune off
and others like him i asked him about
whether he would use nuclear weapons is
he mad enough to do so and he said he
was unequivocal about this he says if
nato does get involved for instance in
imposing a no-fly zone does get drawn in
which he doesn't think is likely but he
says if it does happen there is no doubt
he says
that vladimir putin would consider using
nuclear weapons
well that's quite shocking fascinating
insight interesting stuff dominic thank
you very much indeed and if you scan the
qr code on the screen right now you can
listen
uh to the sky news daily podcast on
today's episode our correspondent shinji
mariiki speaks to our security and
defense editor deborah haynes
and those who call kiev home about what
it's like to live under invasion plus in
tomorrow's edition an update on how the
russian plan is progressing
from sky news's team in moscow you can
subscribe
to the daily wherever you get your
podcasts
this is sky news live from kiev this
evening coming up we'll take a look at
the billionaire oligarchs feeling the
effects of economic sanctions by the
international community
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
they have breached the road there is
a lot of gas being fired all around
[Music]
it is an us carnival kind of atmosphere
out here for prime minister modi's
despite the victory
these students have to find the
prohibited order and now they're going
to be arrested
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
the roads have been inundated the only
way out is to get people by boat
this on any given day would have been
bustling with people but today it's
absolutely deserted
i'm never lazarus and i'm skies reporter
based in delhi
[Music]
welcome back to this uh sky news special
program on the ukraine invasion the uk
has long been accused of allowing too
much russian money to filter through
parts of society earning england's
capital the nickname of london grad
today one of the secretive oligarchs
residing there broke cover to hit out at
eu sanctions against him uh business
correspondent paul kelso reports now on
the russian money in london
mikhail fridman built his fortune in
vladimir putin's russia a deal between
his oil company and bp was endorsed by
the russian president and tony blair
ukrainian-born and now based in london
he's been hit by european union
sanctions but says he has no influence
on the man waging war on his homeland
imposing sanctions against us here
just create an enormous pressure for us
personally but we do not have any impact
for political decision you say you have
no links to vladimir putin but despite
the city of your birth being under
attack you've offered no condemnation
some might conclude you're more
concerned about your money than your
country what would you say to them i'm
also worrying about the country but i'm
first of all worrying about people who
are working for us
you know we have
a lot of you know very prominent people
in the top management the general image
as i said there's hundreds of thousands
of people working for us in in russia
and you know i i don't want to
to make any
comment which potentially could increase
their risk
he controls a global business empire
that runs from energy to retail from
these london offices benefiting he says
from the transparency and security the
city
offers mikhail fridman has not been
sanctioned by the uk but the government
says it does have a list of oligarchs
against whom it will take action as it
tries to put pressure on vladimir putin
by making life in london less
comfortable and less lucrative for his
super-rich allies
it's long been a magnet for foreign
wealth and dirty money says an author
being sued this week for his expose of
oligarchs
this is where you can hire the
propaganda specialists the prs
the lawyers to defend your reputation
um and of course you can buy
everything from um bits of universities
to mansions and private school
places
also sanctioned by the eu but not
britain uzbek billionaire alicia usmanov
seen here with chelsea owner roman
abramovich
a former shareholder in arsenal and now
sponsor of everton he says the
allegations against him are false and
will challenge the west's attempt to
change the rules of the game paul kelso
sky news
well president biden has just confirmed
he's held a phone call with president
zielenski
he said i just spoke with the president
to discuss our continued support for
ukraine including security assistance
and humanitarian aid as it defends
itself against russian aggression we
will hold russia accountable and our
sanctions are already having a
devastating
impact that's uh joe biden
tweeting there in the last few minutes
this is sky news coming up dozens die in
rocket attacks in kharkiv and a 40-mile
convoy of armored russian vehicles heads
to this capital city we'll be discussing
day six of europe's largest ground war
in generations
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back you're watching a sky news
special programme on the ukraine
invasion let's get more now on the
movement of
russian troops on the ground here video
has emerged of the leader of belarus a
key ally of russia seemingly war gaming
the invasion sky's kamali melbourne and
air marshal edward stringer are at the
screen with more details
we're joined by air marshal edward
stringer to take us through the detail
of the russian advance air marshal thank
you for being with us so as we
understand it the russians are arrayed
on at least three sides of uh ukraine at
the moment they are of course around the
capital kiev around the crimean
peninsula which of course they're
holding and pushing on from and around
the second city kharkiv what does this
tell us as we see where those forces are
arrayed about the russian advance
well i'd like to treat these as two two
areas kamali so what what you see in the
south here is an attempt to consolidate
the hold on territory and to link up
through the cities north of crimea which
the russians took in 2014 through the
donbass and the land bridge uh into into
russia but that in and of itself
wouldn't give them the strategic outcome
they want what we see up here like in
these northern group these are two
thrusts against the two main cities the
capital and the second city of ukraine
and clearly this is an attempt to take
over the seat of government and at that
point force terms or surrender from the
ukrainian yeah and in terms of the
attacks on the cities we have seen a
ramping up of attacks on the cities
specifically the second city karachi
let's just take a look at some video
that we saw from earlier today uh this
is of a missile strike in kokiev uh
marshall talk us through what we're
seeing in this
well what we're seeing here uh
is an attempt at a precision strike and
if that was and we can't be sure but if
that was an iskandar missile 500
kilometer range probably launched from
at least hundreds of kilometers away
uh with um an accuracy of between five
and thirty meters uh and a significant a
large warhead in the thous in the
thousand pound category but what we see
subsequent from subsequent images it
might not actually have even hit the
building and it detonated in the
frontier still causing of course it
causes huge damage you can see it
damages all the building all the way to
the very top significant damage to the
building and of course tragically uh
deaths those yeah i mean that is the
second city karaku but of course there
is as we understand a huge column of of
russian forces making their way towards
kiev uh they're
just outside the capital i think we
think that the column is maybe 40 miles
long we can see it here you can see
that is the route that we're thinking is
taking towards the capital uh kiev now
we can't be certain of course what is in
that con but what does this tell us that
there may well be that number of forces
on their way to kiev what does it tell
us about the russian plan well what
you've got in this 40-mile convoy and we
don't know the exact make-up of it from
the from the imagery we've seen but a
40-mile convoy typically would suggest
something like an armored or a tank
that's a tank division which would have
roughly 300 tanks 300 infantry fighting
vehicles around 140 significant pieces
of self-propelled artillery and then a
load of trucks to provide you know the
logistic tail and the support that that
requires i think we've got satellite
image as well of the convoy that we can
have a look at as well which just shows
the the depth of forces that this convoy
has as you can see there they're sort of
arrayed three
deep
along that road and uh it's said that
it's 40 miles long i mean they look like
transports to me but you'll know
what they may well be yeah indeed these
do look like trucks uh but what this
tells you is the russians must be quite
confident at the moment because you
would not leave
this number of vehicles so densely
packed if you feared air attack or or
ambush from from the side so what this
tells us is probably the ukrainian
forces at the moment are husbanding um
their combat power their fighting forces
and those are probably back in those
cities that we spoke about because those
are the vital seats of government that
they must protect absolutely right the
fight does continue here marshall
stringer thank you very much
the latest situation on the ground here
well there are mounting fears that a
major assault on the capital is on the
horizon as this 40-mile convoy
advances
towards kiev slowly it has to be said
but how fearful should we be about the
future of this city joining me now is
adam thompson a former uk permanent
representative to nato
and the director of the european
leadership network and dr patricia lewis
nuclear physicist and arms control
expert and head of the international
security program at chatham house
welcome to you both thank you very much
and sir adam
first of all how dangerous a moment do
you think this is
i think it's an extremely dangerous
moment not just for
ukrainians but
for
the whole of the russia west
relationship it's clear from your images
of that 40 mile long convoy
and the increasing evidence of russian
attacks on civilian targets that the
russian
uh invasion is about to enter a really
much uglier phase
if that happens ukrainian and western
resolve will
deepen ever more to ensure that
president putin suffers a
strategic failure in ukraine and it will
just get that much harder to negotiate
any way out of this so there's a very
little amount of time left i think now
for the sides to come to
some sort of pause a a an unconditional
ceasefire
that would allow some space for
negotiation
and uh mr adam i mean do you think there
is a chance that that could happen still
before an attack
but i think it is what uh we should all
be pressing for i'm not hopeful because
there is no evidence so far that uh
the
the reality uh of the
world he is creating has really yet
penetrated to president putin who is
in these circumstances the only person
who matters
and
whose understanding of what is actually
happening
to
russia and to the relationship with the
west
may be quite imperfect
and dr lewis i'm interested in your
thoughts about the timing of this
i suppose warning you'd call it um
[Music]
from putin you know talking about his
nuclear alert
yes i mean the timing is interesting uh
right from the beginning he
before the invasion he had a veil threat
to a nuclear threat um and
now taking forces um off peacetime
status and going into combat alert
clearly it's a signal that he
is
feeling under some pressure
but also that he feels he needs to up
the ante
and
make us all very frightened of what he
might do next
and it's very interesting to see the
different reactions around the world as
to um as to what he's said
and do you think it's connected
um
patricia to this you know warning to
nato to stay out of whatever it is that
vladimir putin wants to do here in
ukraine
oh yes that was right from the beginning
stay out of my business it's none of
your business it's nothing to do with
nato
um and then if you do then
there's the possibility of using nuclear
weapons but the idea that he would
actually attack a nato state with
nuclear weapons seems
really a step too far even for the way
he's behaving but the thing is i think
we have to take him seriously
because although we may want to in our
minds dismiss it
he has made good on his threats all the
way through
and um he is behaving in a way
that is quite outrageous quite
despicable
and so
if
we don't take his threat seriously we
will be then unprepared
and i think one of the things we have to
do is communicate to the russian people
that we are not
threatening them in any way
that we are
um we would have to respond but we would
respond in a non-nuclear way um at least
in the first instance so that they are
not under the impression that it's
nato that's making the nuclear threat
which is what he would want to portray
if he could
and sir adam this idea that's floated by
some about you know a no-fly zone in
enforcing some sort of
no-fly zone is it i mean what do you
make of that at all i mean
non-starter
you can't blame ukrainians for
suggesting it but it could only be
enforced by
the united states uh and it would take
nato
uh and russia straight into
confrontation
so
i hope
i hope it is an onstarter
because i agree with patricia that uh
president putin's threats have to be
taken seriously when i was ambassador at
nato
while crimea was being annexed and
donbass invaded
we also had out of sequence uh russian
uh nuclear exercises just as we did
ahead of the
uh invasion this time uh and uh
it's a it's a it's a signal
of trouble to come i think from
president putin although we have not yet
seen any significant shifts in actual
russian uh nuclear status resulting from
uh his uh warnings
instead i think we
really need to think uh
in nato
about what off-ramps
can still be offered to president putin
in the
possible event that he would want to
take them i mean we might consider for
example uh suggesting what he has to do
in order to get sanctions reversed so
far
we've just imposed them without saying
how to get rid of them we need to be
thinking about how we design this
sadly probably long-term confrontation
with russia
in ways that
suit us
do we want some scope for long-term
cooperation with russia and not just uh
out now expensive and dangerous
confrontation and in a shorter term we
need to be and this goes back to your
point about low-fly zones we need to be
conducting ourselves with the lowest
possible
risks of west russia clashes
something that my organization the
european leadership network has
called for for many years is
military-to-military contacts between
senior nato and russian commanders to
iron out misunderstanding
okay so adam thank you very much and dr
lewis appreciate your time thank you
very much indeed i just want to bring
you these uh pictures that uh
we mentioned just a few moments ago and
they seem to show alexander lukashenko
the president of
belarus a key ally of course of russia
mapping out troop movements on the
ground and we're having our experts
analyze these pictures in some detail
and we'll bring you more uh on that
throughout the evening
well the prime minister visited uh
poland and estonia today as western
leaders put on a united front in the
face of russia's aggression here during
a speech in warsaw this morning boris
johnson was confronted uh by an a
ukrainian journalist and campaigner who
told him that nato must do more to
protect ukrainian civilians from russian
bombs
who is from kiev uh this is what she had
to say
britain guaranteed our security under
budapest memorandum so you are coming to
poland you are not coming to kill prime
minister you are not coming to live
because you are afraid
because nato is not willing to defend
because nato is afraid of world war iii
but it is already started and these are
ukrainian children who are there taking
the hit
you're talking about more sanctions
prime minister but roman abramovich is
not sanctioned he's in london his
children are not in the bombardment his
children are there in london
children are in netherlands
in germany in mansions where are all
these mansions ceased i don't see that
i see that my family members that my
team members are saying that we are
crying you don't have a lot to rob
this is what is happening prime minister
well thank you thank you very much for
uh
for your questions and and thank you for
for getting here today and i'm glad that
you you have been able to
to get here and
look i just wanted to say that i'm
acutely conscious that there is not
enough that we can do uh to
as a uk government uh to help in the way
that you want and i've got to be honest
about that
and when you talk about the the no-fly
zone as i said to vladimir uh zielinski
i i think a couple of times
unfortunately the implication
of of that is that the uh the uk and uh
would be engaged in in shooting down
uh russian
planes uh would be engaged in direct
combat uh with russia that's not
something uh that uh we can do
well daria colegnu is the executive
director of the anti-corruption action
center and she joins me now thank you
for being with us it was a very powerful
moment at that uh press conference just
tell me why you don't think the west is
doing enough
it's hard to answer to your question
because you know why we are talking i
have multi my team members who live in
shelters in bomb shelters
there is ukrainian national hospital
with children with heart diseases which
was hit with a missile and these kids
which need surgery are now in the
basement uh hiding from the missiles
my city where i studied kharkiv the
downtown city uh the downtown uh of of
the city was bombed by this iskander
missile so and you know what in a day or
two
millions and millions of ukrainians will
have no access to food will have no
access to medicine will have no access
to fuel so we will be in isolation and
it will be the genocide against
ukrainian people and entire world will
simply observe and we'll be thinking
like this you know
experts from london saying okay let's
think what else we can give to putin i
think the west has to stop thinking what
to give to putin the west has to start
thinking how to punish putin and how to
actually
have strength to stand up and adhere to
its promises and it was my point to
prime minister boris johnson because
ukraine had nuclear weapons and he gave
it up
for the assurances that if anyone
attacks us there will be response and
there will be help and now the uk is
saying we are not even willing to shut
all these missiles we are not willing to
help to protect your sky it's it's it's
accumulating and it's a hypocrisy
but what they are doing is supplying
weapons they are imposing some of the
toughest sanctions and boris johnson's
point
about the no-fly zone
i mean it could easily lead to clashes
with the russian air force and that who
knows where that could lead in terms of
a much
broader war
listen uh
i already heard these arguments
a couple of weeks and a couple of months
ago
that we are not imposing tough sanctions
on russia we are not uh stopping
nordstrom 2 because it will irritate
russia let's give up something to put
him let's let him operate let's give
some money let's take some money from
him let's let his oligarchs who are
actually were criminals to park their
assets in in our luxurious mansions in
great britain or in in french riviera
but this led us to the most devastating
war europe had since the last 70 years
and you think that this continuous
appeasement of putin and afraidness to
irritate him will prevent world war iii
or prevent prevent nuclear strikes and i
will let you i will say something
ukraine has four nuclear power plants
across
across the country and any missile any
time from russia could hit these nuclear
power plants and this will be no more
just the ukrainian territory it will be
up in the air flying across the entire
world and first of all to europe to nato
states and i am now appealing to nato
states saying that it's the immediate
danger to nato that any missile from
russia can hit ukrainian nuclear power
plants and then blow out the radiation
on on innocent people across across
europe so nato has to stand up and a hit
at least missiles i'm not talking to hit
uh planes uh i'm talking that there has
to be immediately invented alternative
instrument to no fly zone which has to
protect ukrainian sky and that's that's
that's that's full stop it's
extraordinary times which requires
extraordinary leadership and which
requires extraordinary and quick
solutions
and just finally in 20 seconds i'm
afraid it's all we've got do you think
an attack on uh kiev is inevitable now
it's happening come on what what what is
the question the attack on kiev is
already happening their missile from
russia was was trying to target them on
the nipro river and ukrainian army uh
destroyed that missile but next time
ukrainian army will fail to do so there
will be water flood
killing one million ukrainian people
come on wake up
this world war three already happening
and everybody is just observing how
ukraine is taking the heat
and applauding we you are so brave
ukrainians but we are not going to
interview we will do the photo
opportunity at the border with ukraine
in poland or in romania wake up guys
okay daria listen thank you very much
for
uh being with us
and
appreciate your time strong views there
uh from ukrainian who put that case to
boris johnson as we saw uh earlier today
well here it's been another
violent day with attacks here in the
capital kiev
and
serious missile assaults on intensive
bombing of kharkiv the second
biggest city
day six of this invasion
comes to an end with a sense of great
foreboding here